it is impossible to be an effective
marketer
without practical empathy treat people
at the end of the relationship like it's
the beginning
invention is not disruptive only
customer adoption is disruptive wanna be
happy build a life not just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside youtube
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and learn the 10 tips
to help you become a legendary marketer
so you can sell anything
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with tip number
one break some rules with sarah blakely
how have you built such trust have you
built such a brand over the years what
do you think it is that you deliver and
what's your philosophy on marketing
because there's a great deal of humor in
it that i see and just authenticity and
warmness how do you translate that when
a company becomes as big as you are
i think you know i've always been really
honest with her and i've always been
really direct and i talked to her the
way that i would talk to her if i ran
into her instead of like through a
marketing spin sitting in a conference
room
so i feel like that i've also been very
vulnerable as the founder and the owner
i mean from the very beginning tony i
was standing in neiman's like once i
landed the neiman's order a lot of
entrepreneurs might think i've arrived i
landed neiman's i was like
this is my chance and i will not not
have this work so i took two years and
stood in every neiman's in the country
and then all the other nordstrom sacks
and sold the product for them wow to
their customers wow i had a personal
relationship with you yeah but i mean i
just looked at the landscape i was like
okay they're gonna put me in the
sleepiest corner of the store where
nobody goes and a sales associate is
making 10 or 12 an hour is in charge of
my fate i was like i don't think so
i do not think so so i literally i mean
the store didn't ask me to i did what
what are called spanx days and i stood
there all day i would go at 8 30 in the
morning i would do a morning rally for
all of the sales associates before the
store opened
and i had to really hustle because the
rule was you really only do it to the
department that you're selling in but i
knew like those three hosiery sales reps
wasn't really
going to make the biggest impact for me
being there so i would run around and
beg the women that sold couture and the
women that sold makeup and the women in
men in shoes i gave free product away i
was like i'm going to give free product
away i was like there's a contest i mean
i just whatever i could do to get them
to attend my morning meeting and i did
this and then i stood for you know seven
to eight hours a day and sold spanx out
of the hoshery department in the
entrance of spanx i mean of neiman's um
without permission which is a big key i
neiman's is really uptight about their
visual and i went to target when i did
this at the time and i bought those
those things that go on your desk that
hold envelopes like an envelope holder
and i put them at every single register
in neiman's and threw three pair of
spanx or four pair of spanx and it would
just walk away
and
ever like you know i just remember
somebody asking me is this do you have
approval for this i was like absolutely
but then what happened was
what happened was everybody thought
somebody else had approved it they
didn't realize no one had approved it so
i was trying to get spanx out of the
corner of the store that i knew it
wasn't going to sell in i was like this
is my biggest challenge well had i not
gone to the place that it was being sold
i probably wouldn't have recognized
that's really my biggest objection is
that the women that are wearing great
dresses and slacks and aren't going even
to the hosiery department won't know
this is there so i had to break a lot of
rules to get it done and then by the
time that they realized no one had
approved it um the ceo at the time bert
tansky
uh said you know they saw what the sales
were doing on this 20 item and he said
whatever this girl's doing let her keep
doing it i literally did whatever it
took to succeed i i when i tell you this
i mean i um yeah i got a lot of
rejection standing there i mean you know
not everybody was always happy for me to
be like hey check this out but i took a
picture of my like own butt i laminated
it in before and after and i stood there
and showed people like this my butt with
like a panty line and cellulite on it
under white pants and i'd be like this
is me look this is before and this is
after and people were like but i also
think that that vulnerability i mean so
many people said to me like sh you i
don't know that you should be the before
and after butt model as the founder
and i'm like but i need this product
like this is the whole why and you know
so i just was connecting with people
that way but you know what else happened
is i built a sales force that wasn't on
my payroll because every store that i
hid
became an advocate for me and my brand
they were rooting for me and i had spent
that whole day there getting to know
them and selling them on why this was
such a great product but i wouldn't
leave a store without talking to every
employee including the ladies that did
gift wrap
i would run back to gift wrap and be
like hi i'm sarah this here's my picture
hello i know you're gonna love it you
know i mean it's just like i didn't want
to leave one stone unturned especially
if i'd taken the time to fly there and
go there because it was expensive
and i told my team back home one time
tony i was like i'm going to california
and because the flights are really
expensive i land in san diego and 21
days later i leave out of san francisco
and i'm hitting every store between san
diego and san francisco that's
extraordinary and i had map quest at the
time and i was like freaking out i don't
know where i was half the time and i did
every single day including sundays for
21 days tip number two generate word of
mouth with elon musk how aside from
making great products how do you get
people excited about tesla there's a lot
of people i know and that i talk to who
are just intrigued and interested and
excited about tesla as a company the
thing i really focus on at tesla is like
we really put all the money into an
attention to trying to make the product
as compelling as possible so um
because i think that really the way to
sell any product is through word of
mouth so if if
one somebody gets the car they really
like it they and and actually the key is
like to have a product that people love
um and and generally people
that um you know if that a party or
tour friends or whatever um you'll talk
about the things that you love
but you know if you just like something
it's okay you're not gonna care that
much but if you get the reactions from
the highs and the lows yeah you've got
to make sure you have a really you're
going to
you're going to talk you know and and
then that'll generate work during word
of mouth and that's basically how how
our sales have have grown like we don't
we're not spending money on advertising
or endorsements or
and
so anyone like buys our car they just
bought it because they they like the car
and you know it's like it's genuine tip
number three love your customers with
tony robbins treat people at the end of
the relationship like it's the beginning
and there won't be an end
and that's not just your intimate
relationship what if your customers what
if you fell in love with your customers
with your clients more than your product
more than your company
if your entire life is about meeting
their needs if you would do what for
your customers clients you would do what
if you love your customers and clients
you do anything guess what they're gonna
love you
but most people love their customers and
clients as long as they buy from them do
what they want respond to them
and when they don't they go that's the
end
you want clients for life not just
customers fall in love with them
it's a different focus isn't it it's a
different meaning
and that creates a different life
because you make decisions differently
from that place tip number four study
those crushing it dean graziosi if i was
gonna if you were to start a business
tomorrow i would say what you should do
above
everything else
is find the closest competition that's
successful even if it's not the exact
product something similar and stalk them
stock every bit of their marketing over
everything else i mean every detail
don't just look and say oh they're using
blue and logos no look at the wording
look at the messaging why are they
getting people to take action what does
their first website look like or their
opt-in page what is their registration
page if they're an online business what
is their follow-through what does the
sales video sound like look like what
does it talk about what are the key
words what are the headlines if you get
an email from the company what's the
subject line what's written in the email
what does the link look like and then i
would order the product do what
entrepreneurs do best cut a check for
speed order the product order the
similar product or something in the same
genre how does the product get there
what are the shipping options how long
does it take to arrive when it arrives
do you get an email and what's the email
say does it offer you additional
products when you order the products
does it offer you additional products at
a discount or additional services that
you can help with when the product gets
there dissect it pull it apart then as
far as product goes how can you improve
a problem improve upon the product how
can you put a unique twist on it how can
you go upstream and make it one step
better disqualifying the competition
making yours the universal piece
what i'm saying is
most people focus on the products the
colors the look the feel ask opinions
most of your energy has to be obsessed
on the marketing to get people to want
what it is so you can serve them yes
make your product the best on the planet
but once you do your product your
service your idea your company the
houses you sell whatever it is you want
to do
make sure it's the best but once it's
the best your obsession has to be on
marketing marketing and sales are the
oxygen for every successful business but
people will spend 90 percent of their
energy on the completely wrong things go
oh i'm just gonna put it out there and
if i build it they will come if i put it
for sale they'll take it that's simply
not true that's field of dreams that's a
movie with kevin costner if you build it
they will come they won't come they will
never come
you focus on marketing read books on
marketing read books on copywriting find
competitors that aren't even in they're
not competitors they're not even the
same genre as you but they're killing it
online or killing it with their retail
store and see what they're doing see how
they treat their customers see how their
customer service sounds
guys if you want your own business to
thrive or you want to start your own
business you got to throw away most
everything you're taught because they're
all wrong what is it 70 of all
businesses fail within the first five
years this is why the focus is wrong
listen are there outliers where you
build it and they come yes that's one in
a million then there's another gazillion
people trying working their asses off
and i'm not saying it's it's laziness
sometimes it's the hardest work ever
but if it doesn't sell if people don't
buy it people don't talk about it if
people don't refer it then it's just a
really great idea and then once you
start
once you start getting marketing going
once you start obsess on the numbers
obsess on your sales numbers find out
how much it costs to acquire a customer
and then obsess on different pages on
different writing on different headlines
on different emails to get that cost per
acquisition down whether that's buying
houses whether that's selling people a
book or information product or nothing
online a retail store cost see what it
costs to get a client focus on marketing
focus on sales stalk your competitors
stop asking the wrong questions start
reading books and following people who
are crushing it so what's up man it's
good to see you i i see you all over the
place i see you hustling i see your
impact in lives doing amazing stuff on
youtube i want to share whatever works
for you know you're following my
following today but i want to share dude
your book built to serve you are built
to serve there's a difference when
you know this is i've been an
entrepreneur for entrepreneur for over
30 years i've been in the self-education
industry for 24. it can't even seem
doesn't even seem possible
but there's a lot of people that when
you kind of meet your heroes or you meet
the people behind the book
a habits book a built to serve book a
time management it's like you beat you
meet the guy with the time management
book and he's late getting on stage and
stressed out of his mind in the green
room like
there's no congruency is what i wanted
to say and before we chat today i just
want to honor you and give you
congruency this what you wrote in this
book is really who you are man you are
built to serve you reach out to my team
all the time and
want to help with youtube and tell us
what we're doing wrong and it's not
you're not doing it because of finances
you're not doing it because you're
trying to get an edge you're doing it
just because this is who you are man so
i love seeing you out there i love
seeing you grow i love seeing the impact
you're making
cool man appreciate it i'm still working
on accepting compliments so um
i'll just say thank you oh then i'm
going to keep doing it through this
entire thing to make you feel
uncomfortable oh great classic dean all
right cool well you know i also in that
story um
you know you've been really helpful in
getting that book out i remember when i
came to puerto rico and uh was trying to
get feedback on
pre-launch you and brendan richard took
time backstage while you're doing your
big event people paid all this money to
come there and you took time over lunch
for 40 minutes to do a deep dive
on my strategy um and just super
grateful that you guys did that and you
hooked me up with your warehouse and you
know a whole bunch of things that
dean's a big reason why the book is has
uh uh
just a little piece man just what's up
everybody i see the highs so listen um
appreciate everybody see all the cool
comments coming in so how can we deliver
some value today how how do we help out
besides um i do gotta plug this like if
you didn't check out uh evans built to
serve you should check it out um the
truth is i'm not all the way done i
freaking love it my biggest problem is
every book i read evan i listen i i have
such a hard time reading i still have
dyslexia it still doesn't stick so it's
taking me longer but when i actually
read a book it sticks so i highly
recommend it and uh
it's just you it's like it's it's having
a 200 page conversation with you which
is which is always cool
cool man appreciate it well we also i
also have an audiobook version i i read
it myself so there's always oh dude
please send that to me tip number five
master communication with grant cardone
i think the the idea of
knocking on doors
you know
talking to people yeah like these are
the skills that are not taught in the
schools this is what goes back to your
question about the school system failing
the
the the required skills
i need a client
like if you simplify the thing that
people like about what we do is we
simplify the business process
i need to make a contact
how can i do that
like how can i just simply
if i'm doing if i'm a cameraman and i
want more work you know how do i
knock on a door or make a phone call get
in front of someone
it's so hard impress them
you know if i go to heron's right here
i'll see how many people don't have that
skill i walk in that i don't even get
hello
you know i don't get hello how are you
doing great to have you here i
appreciate you being here it's so nice
for you to drop by thanks for coming
into cartier i mean it's a 3 million
ring over there i went in there the
other day i can't even get anybody to
show me anything
i'm like how much is the ring
you know they kind of look at me right
can you show it to me do you mind
showing it to me
he showed it to me told me how much it
was and i leave you didn't show me a
second ring or third ring or fourth ring
so those are the skills that people need
right how do i
how do i interact with people
communicate yeah tip number six love the
market with jay abraham the mindset has
to be i am going to be
your most trusted advisor
as your most trusted advisor
i am going to understand you
your hopes your dreams your needs your
problems your goals
with regard to my product or service
better than any of my competitors i'm
not just going to understand it from
a technical point of view but i'm going
to do something that is very rare in the
japanese culture i am going to connect
with you
on an empathic
on an emotional point of view i am going
to commit myself to understand deeply
and clearly
what it is like to be you
so that if i am selling you uh software
or i'm selling you
material items or i'm selling you
services
i have a keen understanding of what
you're thinking what you're trying to
accomplish what's going on in your life
how you are looking at this transaction
and how this transaction is supposed to
benefit or protect or enhance you that
requires you to really fall in love with
the market you serve
and care more deeply about adding value
to them and their life
than merely looking at how you can do a
transaction
the key word in all that i will say and
i think the key
uh thread and all that dr cialdini will
share
is the fact that it is highly ethical
you have to give yourself permission if
you know in your heart
and in your mind
that your company your product your
service
when
acquired and utilized by your
marketplace
improves their life protects their life
enhances their life enriches their life
and
you know that your product service or
your company and team
care more
do more
support more
will
be there for the buyer more you have a
moral obligation you have a
responsibility
you have a commitment that you have to
do everything
ethically
available to persuade that client tip
number seven be reliable and responsive
with vuci tembakueya in my business
today i spend a lot of time with company
leaders organizations who are trying to
understand what it means to be
customer-centric
and i love the fact that people use that
word but one of the things i find most
annoying about that expression is
everybody tells you to do it nobody
tells you how
nobody tells you how to be
customer-centric nobody tells you how to
deliver an amazing customer experience
and i love the fact you know i spoke at
over 200 conferences in 2015
each and every single speaker i had the
privilege of sharing the platform with
speaks about customer experience they
tell you what to do
very few know how to do it
so the past three years my team and i
have spent time trying to understand how
do you deliver an amazing customer
experience when people say
customer experience
what do they actually mean what are the
components of customer experience if i
took the expression customer experienced
and reduced it to its granularity
what would i find
so we found that there were four
components to customer experience 3rs
and 1c rrc we call it
be relevant
be reliable
be responsive be convenient relevant
offer the customer what he needs when he
needs it
a lot of us in businesses and i've seen
this sitting on boards myself
we came up with a strategy five years
ago
to do something and we plow down the
strategy to do this thing
the market changes the customer changes
his needs change
but we've already committed resources to
the strategy so what do we do we just
keep going down the path we've been
going down it's the titanic approach
right just keep plowing down this path
because this this thing this business
we're running is too big to change
course quickly
and so relevance is about offering the
customer what he needs when he needs it
be reliable
what does reliable mean
it means timeliness
right
and timeliness is so important but it
also means even more important
consistency
consistency
let me break down a myth here a lot of
people think consistency is ultimately
about
whether or not
we have amazing i.t systems in the
business
it
as a platform enables you to deliver
more consistent customer experience it
in and of itself doesn't deliver the
experience it is simply an enabler to
deliver the experiences
what does it really take to deliver
these experiences
we found
is the culture of the organization
so in terms of reliability convenience
is important
consistency is important but on the
consistency question it's whether or not
you have the right culture
that's a good example of this
our dear department of home affairs here
in south africa
has
arguably one of the best
home affairs systems in the world
arguably
the rate at which they can manufacture a
passport and an id
is in the top 10 of many home affairs
around the world
they have an efficient system that
they've spent a long time
building and developing
but for the common man who goes to a
home affairs office
often
it's not a joyful one the experience of
going there
because when you go
there is a disconnect between the
efficiency of the system
and the culture of the organization
so what happens
you walk in nobody greets you nobody
acknowledges your presence nobody talks
to you
you walk into their four cues in the
home affairs
you find a cue you stand in it you're
not sure you're in the right queue
at the end of the hour you get to the
front of the queue the grail of the home
affairs office right
and when you get to the front of the
queue the young lady in front of you
looks at you and says where are your
documents you say what documents
she says there are documents at the back
you've got to complete them
you go to the back you get there and
there's a wooden deck with five lots of
papers each of these a different color
you don't know which one to fill in what
do you do
you fill in all five
you take this library of documents wait
another hour get to the front of the
queue and then when you do you're told
that the system is offline
because even though the organization has
an amazing i.t back end
the culture
doesn't support the ability and the
efficiency of the system
and so when we talk about delivering a
consistent customer experience
consistency
is where culture
and system architecture and efficiency
connect
where we enable our people to deliver
but they understand they are better
enabled by our systems
so that's
on the reliability question will they
speak about convenience
be where the customer needs you
when the customer needs you
and finally be responsive
this in our experience now remember we
run a research firm
so we research organizations
we found in our experience this is the
most interesting one
organization's inability to be
responsive
what is being responsive mean
it means listening
and listening not with the intent to
respond
listening with the intent
to understand
understanding with the view
to act tip number eight have practical
empathy with seth godin so some people
will tell you that the way to make your
ideas spread is to come up with just the
right twitter strategy and put just the
right little icon on the page and
optimize for posting on tuesday
afternoons and all that stuff
no
the way you make your idea spread is you
make an idea worth spreading
it seems super simple
but it's worth doing so if we think
about you know
psy the most viral
video for 10 years doing the gangnam
style dance he wasn't a brilliant social
media maven
he just made the right video for the
right people in the right way on the
right day
he made something people wanted
to talk about
so when we think back to the fax machine
the fax machine worked
because you can't send a fax to yourself
that if you need a fax machine you need
other people to have one too
so you can send them a fax so you told
them about the fax machine it works
better if i talk about it
same with tom's shoes tom's shoes work
better if i talk about them it's really
interesting if you think about a
university like tufts the back window
you get a sticker what's the sticker for
exactly the sticker
is college is better if you're sending
your kids to college if you can talk
about it
and so built into the culture of our
fabric
if you look at lots of different
industries is is it better
if you talk about it there's a company
that makes caps love your melon and
their idea
is that they can
put these hats into the world in a way
that raises money
for kids with cancer well that's a great
cause but lots of people have a great
cause what's the difference
the difference is you're not buying a
cap you already have a cap your head is
not cold why did you buy this you bought
it so you could tell other people
about what it was when it's sitting on
your head right next to your face and
there's that big square on it people
what's that and you get to say i'm a
better person than you because i bought
this cap you should buy one too so we
gave people something to talk about but
you must begin with the product not with
the gimmick so here's a big idea which
is it is impossible to be an effective
marketer
without practical empathy so what is
practical empathy it's not oh i feel bad
for you you must be having a bad day
practical empathy is
i don't know what you know
i don't want what you want i don't
believe what you believe and that's okay
if you can't say
and that's okay
then you can't make any connection
but if you can
then you can say to yourself but if you
learned what i want to teach you maybe
you'd get happier because then you could
start engaging with what we built for
you
so now i'm a teacher
and you're enrolled in what i'm teaching
because i had empathy for where you
started
and so those steps have to happen we're
not in charge that in the old days when
there were three tv networks you could
buy an ad on all three at the same time
you were in charge
not anymore
it is entirely possible that advertising
will help what you do and there are two
kinds of advertising brand advertising
direct response advertising direct
response was tiny direct marketing tiny
when i came up you know the ads in the
back of a magazine 800 numbers that was
it
but facebook google those are direct
response media you can measure them
direct marketing is measured marketing
brand marketing on the other hand is
unmeasured and that's okay
if you're trying to sell a brand of
vodka because no one
clicks on an ad and gets vodka delivered
to them that's not how vodka works what
happens instead is drip by drip no pun
intended you learn to have more steam
for this brand of vodka so when we think
about for example a podcast
it's a mistake
to sponsor a podcast and have the host
read out and visit blah blah blah slash
whatever as if you're going to track it
they're listening in their car they're
listening while they're jogging it's not
going to work but a sponsorship can work
great because it can raise my esteem for
the brand so
if you have the money and the patience
advertising can pay off if you are
specific
and if you are one of the few people few
organizations that can profit from
direct
response advertising go do it because
every ad pays for itself by infinity
but that's rare it's not the normal
well what we're saying to people when we
show up as a marketer
is
i will change you
and what we mean by that is if you're
the kind of person that wants this
and you're the kind of person that
believes that
my thing my service
my product will get you this
so we have to be very specific about the
who if you're the kind of person that
wants this if you're the kind of person
that believes this so
so many examples i can give you if
you're the kind of person that loves old
movie musicals and would really like a
night out you're that kind of person
our showing on saturday night of the
wizard of oz outdoors in the park
will make you feel like you're part of
something
that's a marketing promise that's not
send an email to everyone saying want to
come and see the wizard of oz totally
different ways of talking to people the
right people about the right thing
and the mistake we make is we get
inconsistent we say we're talking to
these people but we make something that
these people would prefer
and when they're not in alignment
it doesn't work tip number nine pursue
customer adoption with jeff bezos
customers like um the successful
experiments by the way this is a a giant
misconception in um
a lot of young entrepreneurs
inexperienced entrepreneurs that they
meet one of the things that is very
fashionable right now is to talk about
how disruptive their business plan is
going to be
and um
but invention is not disruptive only
customer adoption is disruptive at
amazon we've invented a lot of things
that customers did not care about at all
and believe me they were not disruptive
to anyone
so it's only when customers like the new
way that anything becomes disruptive
and so really it's just saying that you
want to you know if somebody comes to
you with a business plan that they claim
is disruptive you should ask them to
explain it to you in simpler language
and the simpler language is why are
customers going to adopt this
why are they going to like it why is it
better
than the traditional way and tip number
10 the last one before some very special
bonus clips is analyze your customers
with gary vaynerchuk i day trade
attention and build businesses when you
day trade attention eyes and ears are
very important what i learned and this
is by the way this is the stereo i would
literally be on a baseball card show and
i'm gonna i'm gonna paint it for you
because it's really important i would
literally like i would get there at 6 00
7 a.m the show would open at 9 00 7 8
a.m and i would
have my table and i would sit there for
hours garrett pay attention and i would
sit there for hours and i would do this
and then this and then this and i would
look and i'd come around
and i'll never forget this i'd always
come around i try to understand it from
that perspective i would pay attention
to what the other dealers were doing and
so i'd be like okay he has a lot of
boxes here so like if i go white space
here i gave a lot i'm a kid i'm 13 i'm
14 and i'm thinking about how would you
walk through this mall and if you just
saw that guy's table what does my table
have to do so that you're not you know
there's 80 tables here what would you
have to see there that would then make
this stand out in the context of that
and that
and then what could i do and if you look
at this table this is the big punch line
right the orange thing so let's call
that the ken griffey junior rookie card
do i put in the middle but then it's
hidden by all the other cards do i put a
top left corner and it's funny even as a
kid and this is how i understand
websites i understood that that's how
people read so i would put my flashiest
hardest core hottest items in the top
left corner because i understood that
that's how the eye would look at it and
be like whoa there's stuff here
you know to me that's a really
interesting insight to how i roll it's
how i think about the first five seconds
of this video when you watch it it's how
i think about my tweets it's the it's
how i think about my opening line when i
give a keynote speech that all of you
have seen and the cliche how many people
know who i am who don't know who i am
everybody raises their hands oh that
hurts hahaha humility because i'm about
to deploy a lot of ego
so
you know for all my yeah
i'm quite calculated and that's how i
thought about it and so what i would
tell you patrick is it
patrick pay attention to the eyes
understand the context think about the
parking lot flow of the vegetable market
and think about what most people walk
through and how do you have and do you
have a vegetable that nobody else has uh
do you have a better price on something
that nobody else has understand what
they just saw understand where they're
going where's the bathrooms and the
porta-potties where's the honey lady
like there's the sausage guy like i'm
the only person that sells pickles in
this entire row think think think and
then
when you sit down and watch in your
first table just watch that's all i did
i was like a weird i looked like a weird
dude probably because i would just watch
and i would watch like a goddamn hawk
and i would just watch and see their
eyes and then adjust and be like maybe
that wasn't working counter-punching
their attention now i've got a really
special bonus clip that i think you're
going to enjoy but before that it's time
for the question of the day i want to
know what was your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week the sign
says that when you just watch a video
you get motivated to get inspired you
have a 35 chance of following through on
your goals 35 that's not enough that's
not enough just to get motivated believe
nation we're here you're here today
matters you're an action taker
when you commit to a plan of action of
when and how you're going to follow
through when you write it down you have
a 91 chance of following through and
when you commit publicly to somebody
else that jumps to 95 percent chance
from 30 something percent to 95 chance
of you following through believe nation
we need to make this happen so question
of the day your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
specific for the next week put it down
in the comments below and i'm going to
show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate you
making a product that people love starts
with you making something that you love
really think about it would you buy from
you would you subscribe to you would you
comment and tell your friends about you
in our rush to get rich to make money we
push products out that we don't love and
if you don't love them people around you
won't love them either so look at my
youtube channel as an example i love my
youtube channel i make my youtube
channel for myself
i learn it's selfish it's for me the top
10 rules videos the espresso videos the
content that i bring together i need it
it's my education i love my channel i
would share my channel with other people
if i saw my channel and i wasn't
creating i'd be the first thing that i
subscribed to it would be much watch
youtube for me
i need it and if you guys didn't like it
i would still create it for myself it
wouldn't have as much editing and fancy
effects and all that stuff but i would
still do it because i need it for me i
make it for myself
selfishly and then i share it with you
guys and thankfully you guys like it
enough that i can turn a business from
it and continue to hire team and create
more content and pump more stuff out but
as much as i think that my channel still
needs to get better and grow and improve
and i still suck and i need to
continuously get better at the work that
i do i think my channel deserves a nobel
peace prize like i think my channel is
amazing
and you have to love what you do you
have to feel like the thing that you're
doing yes can always get better but it's
really solving a problem
your product your service what you
create your expertise solves a problem
you know that it's genuinely helping
people if you don't have that belief
you're never going to win this is why so
many people who are certain businesses
when you go and you look at hot business
trends for 2019 or 2020 or
how to win in network marketing and like
what products i should sell if that's
how you're starting you're gonna lose if
you're just chasing trends you will lose
there's nothing wrong with network
marketing per se just most of the people
getting into it are just trying to make
a buck just like how most people get
into entrepreneurship you're just trying
to make money too many people and then
you end up going broke
because the people who love doing that
thing will crush you every day of the
week think about who you're going up
against you're going up against people
in whatever industry you're in you're
going up against people
who have experience who have expertise
who have knowledge and love the thing
that they're doing and you're gonna go
in because it's a hot trend for this
year and expect to win no
now
if you love it
and you absorb it and it's it's for you
and it's must-have you will pour so much
energy so much love so much creativity
and find a path nobody else has seen
before
that's how you ultimately win
that's how you can then start talking
about it start promoting it start
building exposure getting word of mouth
if you want people to talk about you
you have to create something that is
worth talking about and there's no way
that you create it unless you absolutely
love the thing that you're doing so you
have to create a product or service that
you would use yourself you have to
create a channel that you would
subscribe to yourself you have to feel
confident that if your mom was suffering
with a problem that your business could
solve that you would recommend it 100 to
your mom
if my mom was struggling with
entrepreneurship you need to subscribe
to my channel it will help you it will
save you
if you can't be like that yet go back
make it better until you find something
that you absolutely love and pour your
energy into so i'm gonna give you a
three-step process that you can follow
to help you evaluate where you're at and
how you can get better step number one
get out of your space
wherever you are right now wherever
you're working you're in front of your
computer you're at your office you're
your home your base whatever wherever
you normally work wherever you are right
now get out of your space just get out
of your typical space go outside for a
walk go down to the lobby
cross the street whatever get outside
your typical space okay step number two
now that you're in a different space
think about your customers think about
who you are helping think about the
problem that you solve so if it's me i
can go for a walk outside i'm thinking
about entrepreneurs i'm getting out of
my space it's too easy to get locked
into what what i'm doing right i got to
make i got to make 20 videos today i got
to respond to comments i got to connect
with my team i got to learn all the
stuff adds up and forget about our
customers so i go outside and think
about entrepreneurs and i try to picture
the people that i've helped the people
who come to my workshops people who ask
me questions and people will join me on
lives right
close your eyes you're in a new space
now and you think about your customers
think about the people who you help the
people that you're designing your
products and services for think about
them picture them try to picture
somebody right pick your individual that
you know that you are trying to help
picture that person in your mind and if
you don't have a customer yet think
about the ideal customers that you're
trying to target and try to come up with
a face somebody you can look at and then
step number three go back to where you
were go back to your office your
computer wherever you were
with that person in mind and then
evaluate your products
with that person in mind look at your
youtube videos look at your products
look at your services look at your
instagram feed whatever you're trying to
get out there look at your books look at
your books
whatever you're trying to promote
look at them with that person in mind
now you've stepped outside your
day-to-day you're above you're not in
the in the muck of doing all the work i
know you've got tons of stuff to do
you're an entrepreneur i feel you you've
stepped outside you've imagined that
person you're coming back and looking at
your products or services with fresh
eyes with them in mind
do they actually need it
will this change their life will this
solve their problems
and if not
go make it better
[Music]
if you want to learn some marketing
strategies from a billionaire check out
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there the way to
sell any product is through word of
mouth making a product that people love
starts with you making something that
you love i mean i think marketing is the
most important thing this is not just
business entrepreneurs